this area over here what do you guys
want to hear rapper existentialism cool
so existentialism what calm down and do
shout fire you can't shout fire in a
crowded room I'll be like it's time for
a rappers like no we're we're gone
so existentialism do you have it there
you were intrigued by the philosophical
stance of existentialism what interests
you about it no no you can't say a word
that you vaguely heard and not really I
didn't expect this kind of a grilling I
wish I didn't exist right now that's the
absurdity of life wonderful thank you
very much that's good the absurdity of
life existentialism let's come to this
side what do you guys want a wrapper car
accidents important what did you say
Cleveland car accidents is way more
exciting
maybe maybe car accidents in Cleveland
cool Cleveland car accidents
existentialism and the absurdity of life
back in the room let's get you involved
want to hear about that
what was that Lakers we had them
suggested a during a Christmas show last
month so I can't tell that again
calculus simple yet did you review hit
pretzels pretzels as a food BIOS heard
calculus so prep pretzel calculus yeah
pretzel calculus car accidents in
Cleveland the absurdity of life and
existentialism this this area of the
front of the room watch waraqa wanking
yeah
[Applause]
for there for those of you that don't
know well that is um you will learn show
us my gosh you are very attractive I'm
married to a woman isn't that weird
people get confused like you gay or
British no just British that's that's
how we sound guys over here so so far
these have been really good suggestions
we had existentialism and the absurdity
of life car accidents in Cleveland
wanking we had pretzel calculus you guys
are the last one to go
Ouija boards yeah cool I like that I
like your Deadpool has whoa it's real
cool I don't really this sarcasm
I'm sorry okay I like that have you ever
done a Ouija board have you ever done a
Ouija board your friends too scared to
do it you guys are like in your early
thirties what's wrong with you
no we believed you believe in spirits no
why you scared then you just don't want
to touch another dude's hand on the
glass or something like no weird uh okay
cool great suggestions just to remind
you the suggestions existentialism and
the absurdity of life car accidents in
Cleveland pretzel calculus wanking and
Ouija boards this them lovely people of
the comedy and magic club to close out
the show it's gonna be real fun it's a
freestyle rap that has a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions don't worry it's not be
anywhere near as bad as you're expecting
it to be
you seem very unconvinced let's let's
drop that beat good sir let's have some
fun
I love how quiet you are as well
[Applause]
lick it off off hands having lots of fun
driving in Cleveland on the highway
there I go
oh nice to be in Ohio car great car
maybe Dodge Charger put a little peace
ship yes I would rather get a manual gun
automatic on the gas no really happy but
I never look the mirror when I'm
changing lanes it's like crash crash
smash what a shame not my cars are right
off you take it to the garage Oh
crashing in Cleveland an unholy marriage
of the two words that you suggested a
large velocity ingested when I was a
young teenager in my room you could see
me wishing I never liked stuff not like
a movie electro today whoo what would I
do it means the stranger let me
translate for anyone who does be French
my main life Oh whoo trouble and strive
to be observant see why do we have it
twice why can't we die when we realize
is so absurd right go inside to side why
are you waving your iPhone yeah put it
back down I don't need it there's no
battery more flattering light keep it
down on your phone that's tight moving
on I'm gonna say this guy if you got a
friend up in the sky if they passed away
up in the clouds
hello widget board gather around we're
gonna put order
low-hanging table take a little glass
upside down able keep his fingers going
on it says F and then you then see on
what's next
wheelchair hours we believe them in my
head I do we cheat boards on the tail
the dead I'm down low in Mexico with
that game played by a games company
while shame move on their I'm gonna take
this mic system can't fake here I take a
little peek good this Jewish and I do
mascara could prove this calculus is
basically you're paid good if you can't
do it right then fake good you go right
to the blackboard that's behind and be
like in a beautiful mind Russell Crowe
trying to work our X Y yellow pretzel to
Zelaya why I don't know you just sit
there passive in this club the pretzels
are massive area right there with a hand
on the door never seen one keep
furiously teenage boy having wet dreams
keep wanking no hesitating
I'd go double speed when I'm
masturbating who chooses down those oh
no close the door and then down below
going upstairs in the bathrooms at risk
my mom when she said she didn't exist
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]